whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
he's never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
welcome back everyone it's Charlie
marble dropped a brand new Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 trailer there's a whole
bunch of new footage in Easter eggs so
we'll break it all down I know lots of
theories about how they're gonna end the
movie because this is meant to be the
last time the Guardians of the Galaxy
team in this current form riots together
of course I'll do videos for all the
other Super Bowl trailers they even
dropped a second brand new Flash trailer
with totally different footage I'll do a
video for that too it'll probably take
me the next couple of days to get
through them all be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'm also allowed to post
my Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
review on Tuesday so look out for that
but the big thing in this trailer is
obviously the Guardians going up against
the high evolutionary he's meant to be
the person who created rocket like
rockets bad space dad most of the
Guardians movies revolve around bad
space dads Thanos then ego The Living
Planet all terrible fathers Now High
evolutionary couple big changes from his
comic book backstory that I'll explain
as we go through the trailer but the
brand new songs they play on this
trailer is Since You've Been Gone by a
rainbow they actually used some rainbow
when they were promoting Thor 11 Thunder
like a lot of classic rock and roll
songs in Marvel movies now but James
Gunn is using this song in particular
because it's a metaphor for the
Guardians being gone for so long like
we're back finally One Last Ride and
because Gamora has been gone for so long
like Peter Quill is so bummed out at the
beginning of the trailer but charting
the timeline of Marvel movies just how
long has it actually been it's only been
a little while since the events of Thor
love and thunder and this is a Marvel
Phase 5 movie Ant-Man of the WASP
Quantum media takes place a little bit
before it at the beginning of the
trailer rocket comes to talk to Peter
Quill who's getting drunk on Space boost
not really sure what the label says here
there might be a couple minor Easter
eggs in the background a lot of the
t-shirts that Peter Quill wears are also
advertisements for space candy like
candy the James Gunn will invent that
they'll sell around the universe that he
buys there's a quick Montage of action
scenes from different parts of the movie
the beginning the end of the movie when
everything goes crazy this scene of them
slow walking together that was at the
end of the first trailer seems like it's
from the end of the movie and it's in
the high evolutionary space maybe on
counter Earth it's hard to tell where
exactly his actual base is because there
are a couple locations that they travel
to in the movie he narrates a quick
backstory for the Guardians of the
Galaxy in general because it's meant to
be the final movie so he's like this is
what we've done so far these are all the
things we've accomplished together and
they have that joke about what happened
with Gamora like now she's a completely
different person because it's the Gamora
from 2014 that came forward to the
future and then took off and the reason
why she seems like such an [__] to
him why she doesn't care as much about
him is because she didn't experience any
of the things the original Gamora did
starting with the events of the first
Guardians movie and that was the movie
where she started to develop a
relationship with him but when the movie
picks up the whole idea is that that
version of Gamora took off after
Avengers end game there was a deleted
scene where you actually see her
literally walk off while they're all
taking a knee for Tony Stark like all
the other Avengers everyone that's there
is paying homage to him and gamora's
like who the hell is Tony Stark who's
Iron Man and just takes off and at some
point after that she took over what
remained of the ravagers group and she's
just been kind of like a softer version
of Thanos lording over the ravagers
since then like a more hardcore version
of the character all these scenes with
their funny Reunion where she's just
knocking him around seemed like it's
pretty early in the movie After he finds
out that she's the new leader of the
ravagers I think the way they played at
the movie it's meant to be a big
surprise for him like wait what it's
Gamora the person I've been looking for
this whole time when they're joking
inside this alien facility it's hard to
tell what's happening during this part
of the movie because it almost seems
like it's meant to mirror them being
imprisoned during the first movie but
they're wearing orange jumpsuits instead
and it might just be a research facility
I don't know if they're actually
prisoners here the other funny Easter
egg for the first movie is that he's
holding the orb there while they're
talking about the events of the first
movie remember in that first movie The
Power Stone was inside an orb so there's
probably lots of references to all the
other Guardians of the Galaxy movies and
all their other Adventures this wooden
looking Marvel Studios logo if you
couldn't tell like the wide version of
it is meant to be a reference to Peter
Quill's tape player from the first movie
that ship wound up being destroyed but
obviously like I said they're
referencing things from that first movie
when they come up on this planet and
Peter Quill looks flabbergasted
absolutely surprised it's meant to be
counter Earth so the whole idea with
counter Earth is that in the comics
Herbert Windham starts out as this
normal scientist and wants to perfect
himself and winds up becoming turning
himself into the high evolutionary
through experiments his whole thing is
that he wants to create the perfect
being the perfect race and he feels like
our version of Earth like the normal
Earth that he came from isn't enough so
he winds up creating counter Earth as a
sort of place for him to experiment with
that idea so that the Avengers other
superpower beings couldn't just see it
with the naked eye like wait a minute
there's another planet that looks just
like Earth what's going on here in on
counter Earth his big thing was
experimenting with human animal hybrids
which is where we get to the Adam
Warlock backstory there's like a big
intersection with Adam Warlock in the
high evolutionary because in the comics
the high evolutionary is the one that
gave him the Soul Stone now he does have
a gem in his forehead in this movie but
obviously it's not the Soul Stone
because Thanos atomized those but when
they go to counter Earth that's why it
looks exactly like Earth like this
creepy version of Earth with a bunch of
human animal hybrids a lot of these will
probably be references to the comic book
versions of the characters this actually
looks like Rocket's actual origin story
like as they're walking around this
chamber here in the center you see like
a version of Rocket that's slowly being
experimented on so that he can talk and
he can walk on two legs this seems like
the high evolutionaries home base like a
lot of the action scenes take place here
a lot of the debris the big fight scenes
that they have it's hard to tell if this
is near the giant space but that they
travel to in the other trailer like
there's this giant scene that looks like
a giant Celestial size space anus that's
part of the joke of the Guardians of the
Galaxy movies like you have a
celestial's head of nowhere which they
actually own now they bought that from
The Collector during the Guardians of
the Galaxy Christmas special we had a
Celestial head there's a dead Celestial
sticking out of the Indian Ocean on
Earth currently now we have a giant
Celestial [__] this is the first time
we've seen the high evolutionary without
his comic book armor on like he's
wearing more casual clothing he already
looks a little bit different from the
comics like he wears red armor in the
comics and he has a face plate but the
reason why he wears that reason why his
face is covered in the comics is because
it's been so Twisted because of all of
his experiments you see him use his
powers a little bit later in the trailer
like he's floating down the hallway he
has all kinds of powers in the comics
it's one of those situations where
because he's trying to evolve himself
thus the name High evolutionary he
continues to give himself more and more
Powers over time making himself more
powerful this is another version of
Rocket's origin story tiny baby rocket
getting terrified the way that James
Gunn talks about the character he was
totally happy to just exist as a normal
raccoon he did not want to be turned
into what he is now even though he's
done all these great things he's had all
these Great Adventures made all these
great friends and family he's still
really bitter about what the high
evolutionary did to him in Rocket's
whole speech here I think is meant to be
a metaphor for just the general themes
of the movie itself when he says the
high evolutionary didn't want to make
things perfect he just hated the way
that things were the whole message is
meant to be you're perfect the way you
are you don't need to change yourself in
the way that all the movies have very
broad themes the knife in the number are
references to Rocket's experiment number
like he was just referred to as a number
by high evolutionary you actually see an
Easter egg for that in the first
Guardians of the Galaxy movie when they
do the big lineup and they show you his
entire backstory the half-world Easter
egg is where rocket is from in the
comics in the comics his backstory was
completely different maybe they'll have
some Easter eggs for half World during
this movie couple big action scenes
especially with nebula they show you
that she's gotten a couple of new
weapons too like she heats up this blade
that she shoots out of her arm this
scene of them in the spacesuits
everybody keeps asking about is this a
reference to among us because they look
kind of like the characters from Among
Us or is it a reference to the colors of
the Infinity Stones because they're all
the different colors of the Infinity
Stones what James Gunn actually revealed
is that all these different suits are
meant to be a reference to 2001 Space
Odyssey like they're not meant to be in
Among Us reference and they're not a
reference to the Infinity Stones this
giant space anus that they're traveling
to either belong to a huge creature or
it is part of a Celestial like a dead
Celestial High evolutionary is
experimenting on which is an idea that I
like more like the whole idea that high
evolutionary would love to get his hands
on more Celestial Tech celestials are
meant to be the most powerful beings in
the universe next to other Cosmic
characters with a few Exceptions there
are a couple characters that are a
little bit more powerful than the
celestials but not that many so
characters like Kang for instance have
Celestial symbols on his technology and
all the Ant-Man the WASP quantumania
trailers of course Kang would also want
to use Celestial Tech because it is the
most advanced Tech the high evolutionary
would try to do the same thing if he
could these are just more scenes of the
Guardians of the Galaxy versus the high
evolutionary in his home base most of
the big action scenes later in the movie
seem like they take place here we see
craglin wearing yandu's Fin and holding
his arrow in front of him he's been
slowly getting better and better with
the era over time like when he first got
it he was terrible then he got a little
bit better by the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special I think the idea
is that now he can actually use it
pretty decently usually they use
Cracklin for jokes though so there'll
probably be some comedy behind that big
reminder that craglin is also played by
James guns real-life brother who's also
the stand-in on set for Rocket because
Bradley Cooper only does the voice we
get a very ominous voiceover from Drax
where he makes it sound like he's going
to try and sacrifice himself I did a
video recently about how the logos
reveal who's gonna die at the end of the
movie but it might be a fake out where
rocket just tries to sacrifice himself
and then Drax winds up saving him and
sacrificing himself because Dave Batista
did say that this was going to be his
final Marvel movie ever when the high
evolutionary says incinerate them and
he's just wearing his casual clothing
he's probably talking about his other
experiments like he might not be talking
about the Guardians of the Galaxy the
whole idea is they want to make it seem
like he doesn't care about any of his
Creations but they are literally just
experiments to him we get a bunch new
Adam Warlock footage we see him flying
across a bunch of debris he has a bunch
of comic book Powers I don't know how
many of his Comic Book powers are going
to give the movie version of the
character he is meant to be one of the
most powerful Marvel characters though
James then also confirmed a lot of my
theories in that they're playing the
character in this movie a little bit way
they played Vision in Avengers Age of
Ultron born yesterday like all those
kinds of jokes but he's basically a baby
who was just born so he doesn't really
understand people that much and a lot of
his Arc in the movie is meant to flow
with the themes of his original comic
book origin story where he was
originally created to be a weapon and
then slowly learns over time to figure
things out on his own and kind of
balances out usually when people think
of the character they think of him as
being a good character but he's gone
both ways and there's the whole Mages
personality I'm not expecting them to do
a whole lot of major stuff in the Marvel
movies at least right now but they could
always do that in the future in the
comics he was created by a separate
group on Earth but eventually he left
them and just traveled the Galaxy trying
to learn new things just learning about
cultures people Society those travels
took him to the high evolutionaries
counter Earth where High evolutionary
formed a bargain with him to help get
rid of man Beast which was one of his
human animal hybrid Creations that had
gone crazy and as part of that high
evolutionary upgraded him with the soul
gem also when Adam warlock went to
counter Earth to try and deal with man
bees the people that were living there
that he was trying to save gave him the
name Adam initially it was meant to be a
Biblical reference like the biblical
atom there's not a lot of religion in
Marvel movies so I don't know how
they're going to explain the Adam
Warlock in this movie but I think that
they're just going to have one of the
Guardians characters give him the name
Groot versus Adam Warlock this is a
reunion scene between rocket and Lila
who was his girlfriend in the comic
she's meant to be another one of the
high evolutionaries experiments just
like him really cool scene of Groot
hulking out with Star-Lord going crazy
the high evolutionary's base I don't
know if he's going to get any bigger
like any taller so to speak James gonna
explain he's meant to be kind of like
the son of the original groups like The
Original Groot isn't coming back this
isn't meant to be like him being reborn
into a new body this route is meant to
have a completely different personality
from the Groot in the first Guardians
movie also kind of seems like he's
addicted to video games really love the
Classic Game Boy Easter egg in the
holiday special too speaking of which
it'll be funny to see if they address
Rock pocket having winter soldier's arm
because Sebastian Stan also talked about
that in real life he's like well I guess
Winter Soldiers probably going to get a
new arm at some point that might be him
giving away a spoiler for the
Thunderbolts movie they might actually
give him a totally different arm but I'm
not expecting it there's a little bit of
Cosmo footage she was featured during
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special because she's a much bigger
character during the movie she was in
the first Guardians movie as an Easter
egg but only briefly in the comic she's
based on Laika the Russian space dog but
in the Marvel Universe She was shot into
space by the Russians as an experiment
and then went up traveling to nowhere
and got bombarded with his cosmic rays
that gave her the special abilities that
she has the reason why she can talk
isn't because she can move her lips she
basically beams her thoughts into other
people's heads telepathically what I
refuse to do any more work while you
demean me all right all right I'm sorry
it seems like they want to show
Star-Lord slowly winning Gamora over I
don't know if that's gonna happen by the
end of the movie because I don't think
either one of them are gonna die the new
fuzzy character beneath them that
they're protecting is just named blurp
he's meant to be like rocket like one of
the other high evolutionaries
experiments this scene of Rocket
fighting on top of groot's shoulder
obviously meant to be a reference to
them doing the exact same thing in the
first Guardians movie Drax vs Adam
Warlock using two energy swords or two
energy weapons he might have one of Adam
warlock's weapons like these might be
two of his weapons and Drax just stole
one of them if Drax is gonna die in this
movie I would not be surprised if Adam
Warlock winds up being the one to kill
him but it always could be something
else at the end of the movie because I
think part of the Arc of the film is
that Adam Warlock fights them in the
beginning and then like in the comics he
slowly starts to figure out that they're
not so terrible and winds up helping
them by the end and I said this in my
video for the last big trailer for the
movie but the Guardians are wearing
their comic book accurate Guardians of
the Galaxy uniforms too from the
annihilation Conquest run where Adam
Warlock actually wound up joining the
Guardians of the Galaxy team so it is
always possible that at the end of the
movie or like in the next Guardians of
the Galaxy Adventure Adam Warlock is on
that roster there's a big Montage of
them just going out in blazes of Glory
all over the place like they want to
make you wonder if anybody's going to
make out of this film alive but I
genuinely think only like one or two
characters are actually gonna die this
funny you're seeing to them slow walking
with nebula holding Peter Quill is
actually on nowhere remember they own
that as of the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special then this funny tag
scene at the end of the trailer with
Gamora and nebula is meant to be a
mirror for Thor and Star-Lord during
Thor love and thunder where Thor started
to lean in and Star-Lord was like no
dude I'm not talking about me stop doing
that that's weird
not me what just listening
knock it off what just never noticed how
black your eyes were where Star-Lord
does basically the same thing with
nebula like Gamora is joking that he's
more in love with her and he kind of
thinks about it for a minute like wait a
minute maybe I am in love with nebula I
never thought about it that way the
funny thing about nebula that James Gunn
revealed is that when they were making
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
and Karen Gillen was kind of developing
the nebula character like the way she
speaks the way she acts they were having
trouble finding something that they
really liked so James Gunn had her
perform the character as if she was kind
of like a sassy version of Marilyn
Monroe which is something that you
cannot unsee anytime you hear nebula
speak now you just hear Marilyn Monroe's
voice like a slightly stabbier version
of Marilyn Monroe don't worry about me
the only concerned about you two
wonderful moon out tonight thanks Dad
sound Fair
this is one fight you won't win the big
thing though is that even though this is
meant to be the last Guardians of the
Galaxy movie with this particular roster
that doesn't mean it'll be the last
Guardians movie ever or the last time
you see the Guardians of the Galaxy in
any of the movies for instance Sylvester
Stallone's Starhawk character who's on
that original Guardian scene like the
Guardians 3000 team he's also supposed
to be in the movie I don't know how many
of the other classic Guardians are in
there too but it's one of those ideas
that you see these space teams pop up in
different space movies all the time I
don't know if there's going to be any
kind of references to the Guardians in
the Marvel's movie because that'll be
taking place a lot in Cree scroll space
I think or at least reference a lot of
what's happening in that part of space
and there are talks about them doing a
Nova Disney plus series or a one-off
special presentation kind of like they
did for werewolf by night that would be
much more connected to the guardian's
mythology because they very literally
spent a lot of time with the Nova core
but the whole idea is that after the
movie comes out James Gunn is officially
like permanently moving over to DC and
not really going to be involved with any
future or Marvel Productions as far as I
know he's kind of half and half right
now like he just released his big reboot
trailer I've already done a couple
videos for that so I'll release it in
the comments below but like I said a
bunch of other big Super Bowl trailers
just released I'll do videos for
everything it'll probably take me a
couple days to get everything out they
also released like a second additional
Flash trailer with even more brand new
footage so I'll do a video for that as
well you can click here for that brand
new Flash Super Bowl trailer video whole
bunch of Easter eggs and click here for
all my other Super Bowl trailers I'll
update the link as soon as I post those
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
foreign